hello everyone and welcome to another
game uh from the ultibox norway
championship it's from the final round
uh and the magnus carlsen is already the
winner but uh we have a very interesting
game between him and levon arun
arundel with the black pieces so i
decided to show this one as well
and then i'm gonna go through your
comments if any of you guys used a
hashtag suggestion to go any
through all and any games that might
have been interesting if you guys
have an interesting game uh you can
still suggested using hashtag suggestion
in the comments
now getting back to this game it's uh
really an exciting one because it's hard
to play
uh especially for magnus he already won
the tournament and he already lost his
uh
uh not losing streak when he lost to
duda also in this tournament so there's
not
much for him to gain in this tournament
anymore uh but
uh you know there's always a 11 to beat
so let's see
what happened here magnus opens with
knight to f3 he goes for the retti
opening
uh we have d five by eleven d4 and the
knight to f6 and uh
sorry about that uh and through a bit of
a different move order
uh we have c for e6 knights to c3 we
again have the queen's gambit declined
on the board we have bishop to e7 by 11
and now a nice trade in the center by
magnus captures captures and bishop to
f4
we have c6 uh controlling the knight
strengthening the center
and queen to c2 a nice developing move
preventing the bishop from being
developed
to f5 and now g6 lemon says
okay i might be castling king's side i
mean i probably will be castling king
said and also i now have support
for bishop to f5 so magnus prepares for
that
he plays e3 he's preparing to block
bishop to f5 with bishop to d3
and that's exactly what we have bishop
to f5 and bishop to d3 is the main move
there have been other attempts here like
moving the queen to d1 or b3
uh but magnus plays the the main theory
so bishop to d3 and we have captures
captures and now knight beat the d7
at some point uh uh well this knight is
coming to e5 so you do want a knight on
d7 to kind of control that square
uh also you are maybe in some variations
preparing c5 the rook can come to c8 and
so on and here
uh there are a couple of uh moves that
have been played here castles is very
popular h3 is very popular
uh but the move magnus place is a new
move and it
is uh in fact the the position from the
thumbnail it is the
h4 move and it's kind of poetic uh as uh
playing h4 against uh levan iron and he
always plays
h4 in in any position like you get you
give him any position would white he's
gonna find a way to play h4
and this is exactly what magnus does
against him so it's gonna be
it's gonna be very interesting and uh if
he just continues
like with normal development let's say
he castles and do you really want to
face h5 i mean it's such a
such an uncomfortable position to play
especially i mean even for a classical
game
even if you capture let's say you open
up the position queen f5
uh you're gonna castle queen side you're
bringing the rook to h1 i mean it's
it's such an ugly position to play for
black uh even though
it uh it's probably okay and you you can
defend
uh but okay after this h4 move 11
decides okay we're not
going anywhere near that we're just
gonna play a5 first we're gonna
prepare for castling and we're gonna
castle then and magnus plays
king to f1 he says i'm not castling
kingside or queen
side i just want my king to be at least
a little bit safe you don't have a light
square bishop so i don't have to worry
about any trickery
and my rook is uh going to be lifted via
this uh
h file here so we have a4
and a3 of course not allowing a 3x11 and
queen to b6 now putting pressure on the
b2 pawn
uh we have queen to c2 magnus defends it
and now
h5 11 prevents uh magnus from pushing
the h pawn all the way
and he says okay now that everything is
nicely set i'm gonna only castle now
so bishop to g5 by magnus and castles by
11. we have
night uh sorry nice day if whoa knight
to e5
uh now with threats of capturing the
knight so after you recapture the bishop
hangs on e7 so magnus
of course level needs to defend that so
rook f the e8 end only now does magnus
trade
uh here there is the possibility of
knight captures on g6 but it's very hard
to
uh to decide all the way what happens
here for example knight captures on g6
f captures and queen captures you do get
your queen all the way to h6 but after
king to h8 it's hard to say
if you will be able to actually do
something here yes you
you do have some options of a rook lift
but it's um
i mean it's it's very hard the b2 pawn
is hanging is going it could be a
problem
and you don't really have any pieces
left to attack with so it maybe it's
playable maybe it's some sort of a force
draw
either way magnus not interested in it
so he goes bishop characters on f6
knight captures and now rook to h3
finally getting that rook into the game
uh there's a there's always time to
capture uh on g6
uh and here uh captures on g6 could be a
problem now because the rook is uh
ready to help out with the attack so
immediately 11 goes for queen to b3
he offers a queen trade magnus needs to
keep an eye on the b2 pawn so
uh queen back to b1 he could trade
queens here
and uh he probably would if if if
uh this was some sort of a game where he
needed uh points in the tournament or
something
but he continues with the aggressive
queen to b1 so still keeping an eye
on the g6 uh pawn while uh locking in
his rook on a1
and here 11 finds a beautiful pawn
sacrifice with knight to e4 and it's a
very interesting pawn sacrifice
uh because it will align carlson's queen
with
levon's rook so here he goes for it we
have captures captures and captures
uh and now bishop to d6
again not allowing any captures on g6
because now the queen will be hanging
here
and you still have some issues here the
b2 pawn is hanging so you have to uh
defend against
everything well and magnus just
continues attacking rook to g3
uh just going all in so now uh you
really have to be careful like
rook captures on g6 will be a huge
problem queen captures the knight is
coming to f7 uh
or to d7 depending on where the black
king goes could be
could be very problematic so here uh
levon immediately takes care of that
bishop captures an e5 d captures an e5
and now queen to b5 with check
re-grabbing the pawn here
and regaining material balance so here
we have king the g1 by magnus and
rook captures on e5 and now we have this
position
where it's six pawns each a queen and
two rooks uh and uh
well levin's king is somewhat more wide
open
but uh you know that's uh nothing
nothing really if it doesn't work and
for example something like rook captures
here still just king h7 and now uh white
is just lost everything is hanging here
so instead we have a queen to d4 getting
the queen out of harm's way and now
rook to d5 continuing the harassment
queen to f6
again with ideas of some nasty rook
captures but just
rook to f5 11 says nope that doesn't
work
and it's a classical game i have all the
time in the world to calculate
everything out
so here if you go for it we can show it
it's a it's quite a king walk so
we will show it because they had to
calculate all of this out during the
game
uh king f8 you could harass with queen
h6 and now
it's either a perpetual uh however king
to uh king goes to e7 and you do
run away for example queen h7 check rook
f7 queen e4 check
king d7 and you even allow rook to d1
check
because after king to c7 there are no
more checks to be
delivered and uh well you're just going
to play rook to d8 and get the other
look into the game
and win this win this game easily you're
up a whole rook so after this rook to f5
we have queen back to d4
magnus says okay we still cannot
sacrifice anything
and now queen to e2 going after the
counter attack now threatening to
capture on f2
so here e4 defending while attacking and
rook back to b5 with rook to b1 now
there's a double attack on the pawn here
so you don't want to allow rook captures
magnus needs to defend it rook to b1
and here queen to c2 threatening the
rook saying okay you move the rook and
only then will i capture the pawn here
but magnus says nope we're not going to
play that we are now going straight into
the end game and now
only now magnus trades down with queen
to d3
uh 11 says okay we can trade but we are
trading on my terms i want my rook to be
able to go to the second rank
uh when the trade happens and magnus
says okay that's fine we have queen
captures rook captures uh
end b3 uh getting rid of
the the backwards b2 pawn and going into
a rook and game
there well two rooks both uh with equal
pawns on the board
uh we have b5 11 defense and now rook to
d3 grabbing hold of the open d file
for his rook we have captures captures
uh rogue b captures on b3 and then now
rook to a4 11 goes for the 44 pawn and
for the moment
uh not the defending with f3 it's
perfectly fine but lemon decides to go
for
magnus that's to go for rook d to c3 he
wants to trade that pawn for this spawn
and okay we have
rook to c4 by eleven and now rook
characters on c2 we have rook captures
on c2 and only now
f3 defending so now i'm not going for
that to trade
uh deciding to to keep uh a pair of
pawns each and only now 11 starts
bringing his king into the game king f8
and the magnus does the same
the other way around king h2 king e7
king h3
and now king to e6 with rook to d3
cutting the king off from the d-file and
now rook to c4
so everything is nicely nicely defended
we have king to g3
and now king to e5 so eleven with a with
a lot more active king it's not
easy for magnus to find moves and the
magnus really took a lot of time
so it was it was a bit of a different uh
uh situation than
in carlson's game against alireza and
carlson's game against elereza he had
infinite time whereas alireza had a very
very
few minutes and it's like that in this
game so it's 11 who has
all the time and it's magnus who's uh
you know grasping for
for seconds as he really spent a lot of
time calculating everything that can
happen in that entire attack
so here rook to d7 magnus goes after the
f7 pawn
and now rook to c3 11 says okay we can
trade captures for captures
but for the moment magnus defense rook
to a7 but now
f6 11 says okay you don't want it i'm
going to save it
we have rook to a8 by magnus and now uh
we have
king the d6 here you could go for rook
to b3
and start pushing your pawn right away
that's one way to go about it
but lemon says uh nope we're gonna guard
the d spawns uh
and then uh if you wanna go after these
pawns i'm gonna eliminate this guy and
start pushing my two connected pass
pawns
and magnus says okay but first let's
improve the position of the king a
little bit here magnus goes king f4
and now king to c7 we have g4 by magnus
and now
king to b7 kicking the rook out of the
way rook to g8 and only now uh
h captures on g4 so we have uh sorry uh
h captures on g4
uh we have f captures and g4 and now
rook captures on a3 eliminating that
pawn
rook captures on g6 and now it's uh two
points eleven
uh uh three points level three points
magnus uh and uh well it's definitely a
race so here eleven starts pushing
because that's what you have to do when
you have past pawns with b4
and now only now feel free to pause the
video
and find the absolute best move for
magnus while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it uh congratulations on
not capturing the f6 pawn because that
simply doesn't work and it loses the
game
so if you found g5 that's fine if you
find the found h5 that's fine
if you found the rook to g7 that's fine
but if you've captured
that's not fine and this is exactly what
magnus played and
this just shows that even he is immortal
uh when uh facing uh well a strong
opponent in an equal end game
in time trouble here we're just going to
show one line for example rook g7
check king b6 uh not along this and now
rook to g8 and now you constantly
threaten this rook to g8 to check
so even if this pawn advances all the
way to b2 you can just deliver a check
and pick it up
and for example b3 g5 let's say
characters captures
and now if black tries to go something
like king c7 or
anywhere on these squares uh of course
preventing the rook from reaching this
you just kick him back
rook g7 check he goes back and then you
go back and now
if he ever pushes the pawn you always
have this check and you're going to pick
up the pawn
and if you try something like king c5
trying to be all sneaky then you go rook
to b8 you have a rook behind the pass
pawn and now it's black who's in big
trouble because now the pawn
is marching up the board so these are
only some of the options possible here
after this b4 move by 11. however magnus
decided to capture the f6
pawn and this is just well this is just
incredible
what happens here because now 11 pushes
b3
and how do you how do you stop the past
pawn uh well
h5 just b2 there's no stopping the pass
pawn so this is what magnus
thought that works rook f7 check king to
b6 and
rook to f8 now so it seems like the idea
is completely the same if the pawn is
pushed you can simply do this
but it's not because now rook to a7
and you have problems here because now
for example if the rook blocks you can
just block with
with your own rook uh so here uh rook to
b8 checked by magnus and now
rook to b7 just blocking the rook and
now you're still threatening the
uh well queen your pawn so here rook the
d8 by magnus
sorry that's not a d8 rook to d8 by
magnus preparing to bring the rook over
to d1 is if the pawn is pushed
but now levon start starts pushing the c
pawn as well
and the fact of the matter is uh his
pawns are just far more advanced than
carlson's pawns
so here uh king to e3 magnus decides
okay you win the race but maybe i can
stop the pawns with my king
c4 11 says okay you're more than welcome
to try
rook d1 and now c3 and this is always
very unpleasant uh due to that grabbing
of the pawn on f6 you can see just
how fast 11 spawns are rolling down the
board
whereas carlson's pawns are standing
exactly where they are so rook to b1
hoping to get rid of that guy here
but just king to c5 now the rook defends
the pawn and c2 is coming
we have king to d3 by magnus uh but
uh after playing king to d3 it was also
on this move
on mu 58 that magnus carlsen resigned
the game as he
of course realized that there is nothing
more to be done here after king to b4
there is not much for you to do you you
your your pawns are so far behind you
can start pushing but after c2 rook
anywhere doesn't really matter just beat
you and it's uh game over
uh there's uh there's no way to play
this
uh and of course it's it's completely
winning for 11.
so it was a completely crazy game magnus
went all out he decided to have some fun
he already won the tournament he already
uh lost his not losing streak and uh
well it was just a
a fun attacking game where a lot of
things could have happened that the g6
square was always the
uh the the question whether to go for it
or not but it never
actually worked um even for you know
grabbing for a draw
uh but uh yeah uh in the end 11 wins and
what a victory it is with the black
pieces in a classical game
uh against none other than world
champion magnus carlsen
so yeah that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it uh
like i said i will go through your
hashtag suggestions so if you have a
an interesting game i've uh missed do do
suggest that uh we're gonna show it as i
i'm planning to show a few more games
from the tournament and then we're gonna
check out the final standings
to see what's what as so far we've only
shown uh carlton's games and we
i'm pretty sure there were some very
interesting games played in this
tournament so do suggest them
so yeah uh that's uh that's the game i
do hope you enjoyed it
i would like to thank uh vincent natale
sudarshan nagash gabriel gross anthony
ryan and david ricardo for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing uh this very very short
coverage of the ultibox norway
championship checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world uh so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day
and do check out the interview with
levin aaron after this game it's the
first thing you'll see in the
description below
see you soon guys